chris evans knows a thing or two about
superhero costumes yes
yes captain america the first avenger is
celebrating its 10th anniversary
and what better gift to give us i mean
chris
then a throwback thursday to when we
first met him
do you remember your first time on e.t
am i in a bowling alley yes
am i in a bowling alley yes yes you are
i look ridiculous
that's too strike in my book were you
like the popular jack like when you were
in school
no no no no i knew him though yeah i sat
next to him in math
was just 20 years old and 10 years away
from being capped
when we first met him in 2001. back then
he was
fanboying over tom cruise it's so cliche
but i grew up on tom cruise movies i
mean i love top gun i love
days of thunder i love you know a few
good men and
born the fourth of july in my eyes the
guys made all the right moves
all the right moves
we remember when chris worked with then
dated his london co-star jessica beale
they were together for five years before
calling it quits in 2006.
and intimate scenes were always a little
awkward you know as an actress so at
least we shook hands you know i knew her
name
chris was later romantically linked to
sandra bullock dated jenny slate
and made headlines last year for a
rendezvous with lily james
i consider myself a very romantic guy of
course chris's first superhero role was
actually johnny storm in fantastic four
to join me i have one single my shirt
off and i always feel so ridiculous
it seems kind of ridiculous six years
later he beat out john krasinski
and ryan phillippe for the role of
captain america we were with him on set
the first time i put on the suit i was
terrified it was
it was you know it just was real that
this was going to be something that i
may be doing for a very long time
i don't mind working out for captain
america we it was brutal
it was brutal you know i had to get
bigger than i've ever been um
and my body's not meant to hold that
much you know i'm naturally a very
skinny guy so it's just about
eating a lot of food you know you just
are constantly kind of
full if it works you win big if it
doesn't work you lose big
chris definitely won big and won us over
to team cap with posts like this
and these adorable picks with his dog
dodger but the part we still want to see
chris
play one day is dad someday i do want to
get married and have kids i think in
the grand scheme of life that's the
stuff that matters the most